For our first problem, we'll have 24x squared and for our second problem we'll
have 9 plus 3 times the square root of 6. Nice thinking for getting those two
correct. For the first problem, we just want to multiply the radicands
together. So we'll have 4 times 16, which equals 64, and x squared times x
squared, which equals x to the 4th. The square root of 64 is 8 and the square
root of x to the 4th is x squared. We want to make sure that we multiply these
factors that come out by 3. So we'll have 24x squared for our final result. For
the second problem we distribute or multiply 3 root 3 times each of each these
terms. Here we'll multiply root 3 times root 3 to get 3. We still have a 3 in
front of these two radicals, so we'll have 3 times 3, which equals 9. Then for
the second term, we'll have 3 root 3, times root 2. We just multiply these two
radicals together to get 3 root 6. There's a 1 in front of the square root of
2, which is what we multiplied the 3 by. 3 times 1 equals 3 and 3 times 2 is
equal to 6. This one's underneath the root. We can't combine the 9 and the 3
root 6, since 9 doesn't have a square root of 6 on the end. These aren't like
terms. So this is our final result.